Welcome back everyone it's Charlie. Marvel
released a first look at the Thunderbolts
movie and some of the plot and how it's connected
to the other Marvel movies so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos there was a
bunch more footage and announcements at d23 about
all the Marvel movies the upcoming Marvel series
I will do videos about everything but this is
their full Thunderbolts Reveal video it's not
everybody that's in the movie it's just the
ones that they revealed recently so if you
feel like some people are missing remember this
isn't meant to be everyone who's in the movie
we've got the return of David
Harbour as the Red Guardian
from Hannah John's Kamen as ghost
not here with us today but Olga
Kirilenko is back as taskmaster
and there's somebody else who couldn't be here
with us today but she wanted to say a quick hello
I'm so gutted that I'm not there in person to say
hi but I am unbelievably excited to be joining
this cast so please from me can you share a lot
of love to my classmates I am extremely excited to
announce also joining the Thunderbolts Sebastian
Stan well listen you know um these are my kinds of
people people they look like a good trouble bunch
and maybe I know a thing or two about that and
I'm just really glad to be back and I guess join a
team of some sort well I I think it lets it tells
you all you need to know about the Thunderbolts
when when beloved Winter Soldier is the most
stable among them love them making the joke about
how Winter Soldier is the most mentally stable
amongst all of them like they're really playing up
the crazy energy of the team like they're all just
a little bit demented just a little bit twisted
and that's going to make it so much more fun
I made macaroni if you want some I know there's
lots of questions about where Baron Zemo is
where's Abomination what's going on with red Hulk
because of what happened with William Hurt passing
away I'll explain them in a second because a lot
of what's happening in the movie connects with
what they're setting up on She-Hulk and what's
happening during the Captain America 4 movie
because it's like the next movie right after
Captain America four of course they're going
to be connected a lot of what they announced for
the Captain America 4 movie confirms our She-Hulk
theories about what they're using the series
to set up with the Hulk characters in the MCU
but the starting roster of the team at least the
ones that they announced like I said are a winter
soldier yelena belova as like the new version of
Black Widow and the MCU Red Guardian is back John
Walker U.S agent the ghost from Ant-Man and the
WASP Taskmaster and Val is the person on the far
left she's just got a little bit of a costume
change and a glow up because it's meant to be
a shiny new promo for the movie so like everybody
has like a small costume change they did explain
that yelena belova is supposed to be the team
leader but obviously Winter Soldier being the most
stable amongst them is probably going to be like
the other person that they look to to ground the
team in reality the way Val is setting the team up
they're using them a little bit more like the dark
Avengers like a little bit more above board so
there are some things that they probably can't get
away with like during Falcon and Winter Soldier
when she was pitching the team like obviously
all of her scenes during that were setting up her
putting together this team she explained she had
the full backing of the US government so like they
are held somewhat accountable but the whole idea
is that they use them for really shady things
that Captain America like the Anthony Mackey
Falcon version of Captain America either won't be
willing to do or they can't use them for because
of conflicts of interest and that sort of gets
into the actual plot of the Thunderbolts movie and
what's happening during the plot of the Captain
America 4 movie like what is it that they're going
to be doing that they can't call regular Captain
America and regular Avengers 4. Kevin feige also
explained during the panels that heading into
the events of this movie heading into Captain
America four there is no actual Avengers team like
they currently do not exist so there's sort of a
power vacuum like you can't just pick up the phone
and call a bunch of the Avengers to rally on the
spot even though in the shangshi post credit scene
it does seem like some of them are still working
together apparently according to Kevin feige they
are not officially an Avengers team I did think it
was funny during their panel that Sebastian Stan
made The Suicide Squad joke like joining the squad
of some kind the Thunderbolts aren't exactly
like Marvel Suicide Squad in the MCU us agent
for example isn't in prison Winter Soldier yelena
belova weren't in prison even though they've done
a lot of really shady stuff they killed a lot of
people they were pardoned for that before this the
whole idea though I think is that Val was working
for someone in the U.S government like it was all
meant to be above board like the US government was
doing really shady stuff having this team and all
the evidence that we've gotten so far just points
to that being Thunderbolt Ross like the person
who's ordering her to do all this stuff but given
William Hurt passing away recently what they might
do is just say that the MCU version of the team
is named the Thunderbolts in honor of him inval
will probably just take all the plot you would
normally expect them to give to Thunderbolt Ross
in the movie and they'll use them more like the
dark Avengers like I said the difference in the
comics is that the Thunderbolts were created by
Baron Zemo in the they were way more hardcore way
more Suicide Squad like the dark Avengers were
a team of anti-heroes and super villains that
Norman Osborne put together to replace the regular
Avengers with ones he could control and used to
push his own agenda within the US government when
he positioned himself as the savior of the world
at the end of The Secret Invasion Arc we just got
the secret Invasion trailer with Nick Fury finally
coming back this evil faction of Scrolls within
the good Scrolls trying to take over the world
in the comics Norman Osborne took all the credit
for ending the threat of secret Invasion it made
the people of the world the US government believe
that he was the real hero using his new Authority
granted to him by the government to take over
shield and hijack all the Avengers stuff like
he also hijacks Iron Man's Armory and uses his
armor to Rebrand himself as the Iron Patriot
like I am the hero everything I do is towards
the good of America and that sort of the dark
rain Arc like a bunch of really shady really bad
characters pushing their own agenda but doing so
with the full authority of of the US government
and that's kind of what they're doing with Val in
the MCU now and the Thunderbolts like everything
they're doing is sanctioned by the US government
that's the twist we can't be evil because the US
government says that everything we're doing is
okay sort of like a make the Avengers great again
kind of meme in the really shady stuff they're
doing is probably related to what happens during
Captain America 4 New World Order and what's going
on with the villain of that movie so this is
where we tie in with all the Hulk characters
there's like a lot of Hulk stuff happening in
Marvel Phase 5 coming up if you didn't see the
Captain America 4 panel they announced some of the
casts some of the plot like Carl lumley's Isaiah
Bradley is coming back so hopefully we'll see
some flashbacks with him when he was still acting
as Captain America when he was younger during
the Korean War I know there's lots of theories
that when Red Guardian was telling stories about
his adventures fighting Captain America he was
secretly talking about fighting Isaiah Bradley
Captain America but looking at the Timeline just
the way they explain red Guardians backstory in
the MCU I believe the Isaiah Bradley was arrested
in thrown into prison before the MCU version
of Red Guardian got the super soldier serum the
Soviets has stolen slash reverse engineered from
the United States side Note 2 you have to imagine
that Red Guardian was created by drakoff inside
the regular Russian or Soviet military because
when they were doing all that it was still
the Soviet Union you have all that going on
through the regular Soviet military but on the
side off secretly in Siberia you have Hydra in
their Winter Soldier program so just to be clear
all the stuff that Hydra was doing with the Winter
Soldier program was completely separate from
what was going on with the Red Guardian program
but the main villain of Captain America 4 is the
leader from The Incredible Hulk the Samuel Stern's
leader everybody been wondering what's been going
on with him this whole time Marvel is part of
Cinema history and that I get to be a part of of
that is an absolute honor he'll probably come back
as a much more comic book accurate looking version
of the character his whole thing in the movie is
that he was trying to reverse engineer the powers
of the Hulk like he was collecting all these
samples of the Hulk's blood that's how he wound up
creating the Abomination character like he was a
combination of the super soldier serum through
the weapons plus program in the leader reverse
engineering the gamma experiments that the Hulk
did on himself in his blood to give Abomination
the gamma Powers so here's we get around to the
She-Hulk plot and the stuff that they're setting
up with the Thunderbolts movie and what's going on
with the Hulk in Marvel phase 5. during She-Hulk
Hulk makes this big deal about burning all of
her blood samples because somebody wants her
blood because they want to reverse engineer her
gamma Powers later in the series a mystery boss
hires The Wrecking Crew villains to steal some of
Jen's She-Hulk gamma blood they haven't revealed
who that is yet but a lot of people think that
it might be the leader because this whole thing
in The Incredible Hulk movie was getting Hulk's
blood they confirmed the plot with Hulk going
back to sakar was set up for the future movies
like there was a big Hulk plot that they would
play out in the movies in Marvel phase five
most of the evidence so far points that being
more of the planet Hulk and World War Hulk plot
from the comics that they just skipped over in
the movies and here's where we connect back with
the Thunderbolts movie because if you didn't read
the comics the first time the Thunderbolts team
debuted it was inside the Incredible Hulk comics
in one of their first missions was going after
the Hulk and they might be doing a version of
that during the Thunderbolts movie and that'd be
another reason why Val couldn't call the Anthony
Mackey Falcon version of Captain America because
he's Hulk's friend he wouldn't want to go after
the Hulk you'd have another Captain America Civil
War situation and even though William Hurt passed
away you have to imagine Thunderbolt Ross's
whole thing is that he still wanted the powers
of the Hulk like all this time since the events of
that movie he still wanted to capture the Hulk so
even though you don't normally think of the Bruce
Banner Hulk as a villain if you think about him in
a world war Hulk context something could happen
to him during the captain America 4 movie that
would drive him over the edge and put him in more
of a World War Hulk state where the heroes and the
villains like in the Thunderbolts case technically
not villains more like anti-heroes all have to
fight him but the Thunderbolts are really just
trying to capture him or kill him so it really
does seem like they're doing the plot of world
war Hulk but they're doing it inside the Captain
America 4 movie and inside the Thunderbolts movie
the whole reason why they probably didn't talk
about abomination in Thunderbolts or Baron Zemo
is probably just because it might spoil some of
the plot during She-Hulk like there's still a
bunch of abomination plot that they have in the
She-Hulk episodes like we see him in regular
form he's been trying to get a prison he just
did that and now it seems like he's pretending
to Pedal this whole Zen new age thing like he's
completely balanced himself he's totally chill now
but secretly I think we all believe that that's
a misdirect and maybe at the end of that series
Val will also show up in a cameo scene to recruit
him for the thunderbols or talk to him about the
Thunderbolts when it comes to the Red Hulk though
because like that's what we've been talking about
like when are they finally going to do Red Hulk
and there's so much Hulk plot that's happening
between Captain America 4 in the Thunderbolts
movie because William Hurt passed away if they
don't plan on recasting the character like doing
some crazy Multiverse twist they could either do
a version of the female red Hulk from the comics
and just give that plot to Val or they could just
make another character the Red Hulk I'll do more
videos about World War Hulk and Thunderbolts when
we get more Easter eggs for them in the She-Hulk
episodes but if there's anything you spotted or
anything that they announced for these movies at
d23 that I didn't talk about in the video just
write it below in the comments and I'll try
to address it my full She-Hulk episode 5 video
will post Thursday just like normal I just did
a werewolf By Night trailer video I'll put a link
for that in the description you can click here for
my Marvel secret Invasion trailer video and click
here for my house of the Dragon episode 5 trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!